Ion is a, was a Saul
Kagan claims conference postdoctoral
fellow in Advanced Shoah Studies in
New York and honorary research
fellow of the Centre for Jewish
Studies at University of Manchester.
His research focuses, his
research focus lies in the field of
Jewish-Christian relations in
Eastern Europe during the Holocaust.
His numerous publications include
the monograph titled The Romanian
Orthodox Church and the Holocaust,
and an article about the
7th Rosiori Regiment
and the Holocaust in Romania and the
Soviet Union, which was
published in Dapim, or is going to
be published?
No, it was published.
Published in Dapim.
Studies, Dapim, which is the studies
on the Holocaust, and that was
a journal article.
Ion will be presenting his work on
survivor testimony to explore the
use of Jewish to Christian
conversion as a survival strategy
during the war.
Please join me in welcoming Ion.
He also has uh, a cold.
Yeah.
I'm very sorry that my voice is not
up to the task, but
Do you want me to read it for you?
No, no, no. That's fine.
That's fine.
My presentation today will have four
parts. In the first, I will
explain, and actually
let me go. I will explain how I
came to study this topic of just
conversion to Christianity.
In the second, um, I offer
a brief overview of the history of
Jewish conversion to Christianity
before and during the Holocaust and
how this avenue was used as
a means of survival.
Third, my presentation provides
some statistical data
on my findings so far
in the Fortunoff, Fortunoff Archive
on this topic.
And last but not least, I will look
at a few testimonies,
including one that will feature as
the annotated edition and examine
some of the major themes that
transpire in them.
During my Ph.D,
which um...
It doesn't turn on.
Well, this is for the
video recording, um, I
don't think we have a mike,
There's a mike here.
Yes, but it's for the video.
Oh okay, oh.
OK,
Take a, okay.
During my Ph.D, which resulted in
the book, the Romanian Orthodox
Church and the Holocaust, published
by Indiana University Press in 2017,
I discovered that in relation to the
topic of Jewish conversion,
the main church in Romania
had to address two issues.
First, there were requests
from Jews who were already converted
to Orthodox Christianity to
be protected by the religion they
have been members of for many years.
Unfortunately, the Holy Synod
refused to offer any help,
not even to those such as Nicolae
Solamonescu,
a Jewish man who converted more than
thirty years before.
Second, there were requests for
baptism during the Holocaust coming
from Jews who believe that in this
way they may be protected by
the increasing anti-Semitic laws.
In the second instance, the Romanian
Orthodox Church showed indifference
too.
Although it had a clear majority
of at least 72 percent of the
population, the church offered
this avenue to only a
handful of people, this being
in stark contrast with the attitude
of the Roman Catholic, Greek
Catholic and Lutheran churches.
When I finished my Ph.D., I embarked
on a new project looking at the big
discrepancy between the attitude of
the Orthodox and the Catholic
churches in Romania toward Jews.
Although the topic of
conversion was not the only one I
looked at, it was one of the most
important as the Catholic Church in
Romania made it a matter of open
rebellion against the state.
And by the way, this is the Papal
nuncio to Bucharest,
Andrea Cassulo.
In Romania, there are two
strands of Catholicism, Greek
Catholicism,
which comprise of
ethnic Romanians from Transylvania,
who at the beginning of the 18th
century accepted to be subjected
to the Holy See, and the regular
Roman Catholics.
Both Catholic churches
were in struggle with the Romanian
state, which favored the Romanian
Orthodox Church.
Hence, in 1941,
when the Antonescu regime
banned conversion of Jews, the
Catholic Church protested vehemently
against the measure.
In the coming years, many Jews
who understood that conversion to
Catholicism might offer some
protection asked to be baptized.
The Catholics seized the opportunity
to show their defiance and continue
to convert in open disobedience,
sometimes resisting direct pressures
from the state to stop baptism.
As the Antonescu regime wanted
to maintain good relations with the
Vatican, which was seen by the
Romanian leader as a key political
player in the future peace
conferences, most youth who
converted to Catholicism during the
Holocaust in Romania escaped
deportation and death.
Lists found in various archives
show that at least 2,008
Jews converted after the March 1941.
ban.
These should be added to the
4,631 Jews who were
already converts.
During my research, I was surprised
by the lack of information on the
postwar fate of converted
Jews.
I remember that when I started my
postdoctoral project, I discovered
at Yad Vashem lists of Jews
who converted to Catholicism in
Bukovina.
I took one of these lists which
comprised of 108 names,
and tried to find any information in
the Yad Vashem Hall of Names, and
other paper and video
archives at Yad Vashem.
At the time. I also introduced the
names in the USH, USC
Shoah Foundation video archive.
Unfortunately, I found nothing.
I even arranged a meeting with the
director of the Hall of Names, who
explained to me that since they
converted, it must be that these
people either did not identify
as Jews, or were not accepted
or seen as Jews anymore.
In 1950s, the case
of Daniel Ruf, Rufeison,
showed that the convert's Jewishness
was strongly contested in Israel.
Historian and sociologist Ariel
Yaakov, mentions--
sorry, mentions
in one of his articles several
memoirs of Holocaust survivors that
discuss openly the topic of
conversion, and it is striking that
all of them were written and
published in the United States.
In the US, the topic of conversion
appears more often in testimonies of
Holocaust survivors, including in
the Fortunoff Archive.
There are several aspects that might
explain this.
First, it is already generally
accepted that the American identity
is based on multiple ethnic and
religious layers.
Hence, one does not feel the need
to define himself or herself
in limited ethnic and religious
terms.
Second, the Jewish community in the
United States is much more eclectic
and the definition of Jewishness is
more nuanced than in Europe or
Israel.
This might explain why a Jewish
convert to Christianity could talk
openly about conversion, conversion
and still identify as Jewish
in the US, but would have
reservations to do so in other
countries.
Third, since the definition of
Jewishness is broader and more
inclusive, some US, US
institutions that gather Holocaust
survivors' testimonies did not
have any problem of including
testimonies of Jews who converted to
Christianity.
This was definitely the case with
the Fortunoff Video Archive.
The project to gather testimonies of
Holocaust survivors started in 1979,
and I argue that from the beginning
it is visible the broader scope and
reach of the project.
Take, for example, one of the first
interviews done by Lauren
Vlock, Laurel Vlock, one of the
initiators of the archive in 1980,
April 1980
with Hans Frei, who was at the
time a respected professor of
theology at the Yale Divinity
School.
Frei was born in Breslau
in 1922,
from Jewish parents were both
involved in the medical profession.
His father was a professor at the
Faculty of Medicine, University of
Breslau, and his mother was a
doctor.
The parents were much assimilated
into the German society.
They converted to Christianity in
their early adulthood.
In 1935, Hans was
sent to a Quaker school
in England as a way of protecting
him from increasing persecution.
In 1938, the entire
family immigrated to the United
States.
The problem of conversion and the
definition of one's belongings,
belonging is in depth debated
in the dialog between Vlock and
Frei, and although I have
not found yet a written document to
confirm this, it might be that this
early interview set up later
practice of interviewing converts
and discussing the way in which
the experience impacted
their sense of belonging.
The Fortunoff Video Archive
contains, in comparison to all
other Holocaust testimonies
archives I looked at,
a much greater number of testimonies
from Jews who converted to
Christianity before and during the
Second World War.
I relied in my findings
on Orbis, the search
engine of the Yale Library.
Each testimony has a brief, usually
between 10-20 lines,
rows in a word document,
this description of its content.
This tool is by no means perfect,
and there might be
other testimonies describing
experience of conversion that sees
the word itself or alternate
version, versions
are not mentioned in the description
are impossible to find.
Using Orbis, I deployed
four types of search.
First, I searched using
the word conversion and 63
results came up.
Of the 63, 48
turned out to be describing, some of
them in great detail, experiences
of conversion to Christianity.
In terms of gender, 28
testimonies were given by women
and 20 by men.
The vast majority were children
at the moment of conversion, being
born in the late 1920s
and during the 1930s,
only few being born before
1920.
Most conversions took place from
1939 to 1944.
Only three took place after
the war and a few others before
1939.
The most striking aspect was the
distribution according to the
country of origin, which was in
most cases, but not all,
also the country where the
experience of conversion took place.
The preponderance of testimonies
from Slovakia is surprising
and difficult to explain,
as it appears in the testimonies
themselves, conversion in itself
was not providing safe shelter
in Slovakia.
So this could not explain the large
number of testimonies and maybe of
conversions in this country.
The possibility that there was,
there was, is a Slovak community
around New Haven, hence more people
were interviewed as a result of
geographical proximity is not
entirely explanatory as testimonies
of the Fortunoff Archive were
gathered in many other
locations.
Another striking aspect was the fact
that there is no testimony from
Romania, including
territories that were part of
greater Romania in the interwar
period and are now in Ukraine
or Moldova, the country
with the third largest Jewish
community before the war.
Moreover, I explained about, as
explained above, the number of
conversions in Romania during the
Holocaust was relatively, relatively
high.
The absence of any testimonies
from this country could be a strong
argument of the way in which
effectiveness of conversion
affected postwar Jewish identity
and I hope we will be able to
discuss these more in the Q&A
session.
After the analysis of the first
sixty three testimonies resulted
from searching the word conversion,
I looked up for three more
variants, converted, baptism,
and baptized.
For the sake of
time, I will keep some details
about those findings that I will
offer an overall summary.
The four searches produced
one hundred and fifty three results.
Ninety seven out of a hundred and
fifty three were testimonies
describing in a form or another
experiences of conversion of the
interviewees, while
the rest were either duplicates
or irrelevant as the word refer
to something else.
Were, all were about
conversions of somebody else,
usually parents.
And the mention was very brief.
Sixty two testimonies were from
women Holocaust survivors
and 36 from men.
The vast majority were children at
the time of baptism, conversion
to Catholicism is predominant,
but this was mostly because most
testimonies were from countries
where Catholicism was the main
religion.
In terms of countries of origin, it
surprises the large number of
testimonies from Slovakia, 26.
This is more than a quarter.
And the lack of any testimony from
Romania.
In almost all cases looked at,
conversion was a means of survival.
It was not the only strategy of
survival and most of that in itself
was not helpful or enough,
but it was always combined with
other means of survival, such as
hiding or providing forged papers.
In some cases, some means of
survival were diffused without
the step of conversion.
Several historians have noted
that until today, the topic of
conversion has been to a large
extent avoided in Holocaust
historiography, but conversion
was not a marginal aspect of the
Holocaust.
On the one hand, as in the case of
the Romanian Orthodox Church
explained earlier, judges
had to respond to Jews who were
already converts.
And I think it is stunning
that the topic is not carefully
discussed when one considers that in
Hungary alone in 1941,
there were up to 100,000 converts.
That is approximately one sixth
of the Jewish population of Hungary.
This, including the territories,
added, added, annexed after 1940.
Although there were converts
deported to Auschwitz and there are
few such testimonies in the
Fortunoff Archive, most
of them were protected as in 1944,
Catholic and Protestant churches
protested vehemently the deportation
of converts.
The number of converts, what, was
high in other countries, too.
In Russia, for example, during the
19th century, the official number of
conversion was 85,000.
Czechoslovakia, although we lack
clear figures, it is estimated
that in Prague or Brno
at the beginning of the 20th
century, the conversion rate stood
at 2.25
or 2.5 percent of the local Jewish
population.
Hans Frei puts the number
of converts in Germany in 1933
at 15,000.
On the other hand, churches had to
deal during the Holocaust with
another aspect: to convert
and if so, under what circumstances,
Jews who are seeking protection.
The case of Romania, where the
Catholic Church converted entire
families in open disobedience to
state, state pressures, is
singular.
In other countries, conversion was
not necessarily an official policy
coming from the leadership of the
church, but a matter of local
initiative and decision.
For example, there were cases of
Jews who wanted to take shelter in a
village, but the villagers said
that they would not offer that
protection unless the Jews
convert to Catholicism.
This situation appears
several times in the Fortunoff
testimony that I mentioned here,
only the case of Ann W.,
Holocaust testimony
2356. Was from a town
called Radzilow
in Poland.
She described the scene when her
father asked the leader of the
village to help the family.
Quote, "he asked him if he could
help us.
There were some other people and the
first comment that there
was from those people was,
'as Jews, we cannot help you.
If you promise to convert,
then we will try and help you.'
Of course, my father agreed." End
of quote.
And since I mentioned on here,
I must stress an aspect that
she mentioned, mentions and
is not very often present in
testimonies.
The role of the parents in this
case, the parents and children, were
hiding together in keeping
alive Jewish identity despite
conversion.
And I have the clip actually from...
Uh
uh.
Would uh, would talk to me.
All the talk was, was this
because--
My mother, my mother would talk,
--heard.
She would talk to me, she would,
being that I was the youngest and I
didn't have much education yet.
She, she would tell me about the
Jewish history
and heritage.
And, eh, she wanted to be sure that
I know who I am, and
the, and who my people
are. And she tried
to instill in me the
pride of being Jewish
and not to think that because we
are exterminated
and eh, and treated the way
we are, that we really deserve
that.
And they, and
she would tell me
stories with the history about
some heroic, especially
heroic events that took place.
And she would tell me that if,
in case I'm the only one
who would survive, to be
sure to somehow get
through a, to a center where there
are Jews and the,
and to, to go to Palestine
and, and go on with my life
and,
and that, that there is
so much beauty
in, in the way of life of
Jews in their daily living.
The re-telling of the story with
this heroic undertones
was definitely influenced by the
interviewee's situation,
belief values, as they were
in the 1980s when the interview
was done.
Still, the scene itself shows
the desire of parents to pass on
to their children their,
their ethnic and religious identity
in a context in which they were in,
that to some extent, foggy.
We should not forget that they were
converted already, hiding,
but they are still trying to
maintain a Jewish identity alive.
Other parents do not have this
chance during the Holocaust.
The conditioning of help in exchange
for conversion appears often in
attitudes of religious institutions
too.
Many Catholic and Protestant
convents and/or orphanages
refuse to take children inside
unless they converted.
For example, David K., Holocaust
testimony 1856,
who was born in Brno,
explains that an Anglican orphanage
based in Czechoslovakia
conditioned the acceptance of the
Jewish children on their baptism.
While hiding in convents or in
Catholic households, many
Jewish children felt persuaded to
convert. Sometimes there were
direct pressures.
Other times there was a
winning over.
Such examples--
we know of the child being convinced
by the context in which he or she
was living.
And there are many such examples in
the Fortunoff testimonies archive.
All these experiences impacted
greatly on these peoples later sense
of belonging.
On the one hand, there was an
internal voice of consciousness
telling them, especially if they
grew in traditional Jewish families,
that by converting they betrayed the
Jewish people, the Jewish religion,
and community.
Take, for example, Susan
M., Holocaust testimony
537, who almost
converted as a child in Hungary
to avoid persecution.
She describes her experience in
these terms.
I quote, "and the issue was,"
this is the voice of the
interviewer. "And the issue was that
you were learning the Catholic
prayers." "Yes." "And you
enjoyed taking
some lessons where you were a good
student." "No,
I was petrified the whole time.
And I wanted to cover my ears not to
even hear it.
And I felt somehow that God was
watching us. And if anything, this
was going to be the cause
of our perishing,
the next air raid or whatever,
just because we were doing it.
It was like, like being
a traitor, and I was always terribly
ashamed.
I don't, I
am not ashamed of anything else
associated with the Holocaust and I
practically talk about anything
else. But this is something I've
always been very embarrassed
about. And I was
glad when my father kicked up
a fight and we got out of
it." End of quote.
Susan M. is only one example
of many others who had the same
feeling of betrayal.
At this interview, the voice of
consciousness, one should also
add the outsider problem.
In many Jewish communities, converts
who are not welcome back, not
seen as Jews anymore.
Sometimes this implicit pressure
can be felt in the Fortunoff
testimonies when the survivors try
to answer and ask questions,
minimize the importance of
conversion experience,
or all of a sudden
bring up Israel as a way of
emphasizing their Jewish belonging.
And I don't know if you noticed,
noticed, even in Ann's case,
she's talking towards the end about
go, going to Palestine.
Although most Fortunoff testimonies,
discussion, discussing the impact of
conversion of Jewish identity have
this tone, there are
several notable exceptions.
There were few conversions after the
Holocaust.
In one case that was designed
as an explicit protest against
Jewish religion and God seen
as responsible for what happened.
So, I found such a case
of a conversion as a sign of
protest.
There were other cases such as
Walter Ziffer,
testimony 1475,
who converted after the Holocaust
and after arrival in the US
out of conviction.
Zimpher became a prominent
evangelical minister.
But even in his case, testimony,
one has the sense of a heroic return
to Judaism after almost
40 years.
Then there are testimonies of Jews
who converted before and during the
Holocaust in Germany.
In most cases, their
retelling of the story of conversion
is not shadowed by
feelings of betrayal or
embarrassment, and
that is probably because this
community was much secularized.
This is the case of Hans Frei,
whom I mentioned earlier.
After long deliberations, I decided
to focus my annotated edition on his
testimony.
Frei's testimony is important for
Yale University as
he was a professor
of theology here, Divinity
School, for many years.
I also believe that this is one of
the first such testimonies from
converted Jews recorded in the
Fortunoff Archive and
it set up later trends.
The topic of conversions impact
on Jewish identity is discussed
brilIiantly in this testimony.
However, this is also a
very different case from most of
the cases I looked at.
Frei, first Frei
immigrated with his entire family in
1938.
He experienced the beginning of the
Holocaust in Germany but did not
feel like most other
survivors the full blow of
persecution.
Frei did not have to take shelter in
a convent, or to
be hidden conditionally by some
villagers, or to convert
as a way of gaining the trust of a
convent or a foster family.
However, his testimony is extremely
relevant because it shows a
different tone on conversion,
where this decision is not dismissed
as a betrayal or embarrassment, nor
minimized under a glorious narrative
of postwar return to Judaism.
Frei try to make peace with these
hybrid identities.
He explains this rather neutral
attitude in this way.
And I have again the excerpt
here.
We had been so deeply assimulated,
you see? So deeply assimulated
that on the one hand, we were
proud of the
fact that we were Jewish
in a curious, undefinable way.
We felt that we were Jewish
and that was that.
Jews were good people.
But on the other hand, we felt that
it was simply a kind
of cultural,
religious distinctness,
but not anything
that interfered with our, first
of all, being German citizens.
You see our whole world--for just
that reason, our whole world was
turned far more upside down
in 1933.
We were robbed of our primary
support. Namely our
national identity,
which was much more our identity
than our Jewish identity.
This is a complex story because
you were converted.
You claim you felt Jewish
or you felt an identification with
your Jewish heritage, ancestry,
yet you were practicing Christians
in an assimilated German society.
It's, uh--
Heinrich
Heine, the German poet
who was himself Jewish and
rather cynically converted,
once said that the-- that
bap-- the baptismal certificate
is the admission ticket to European
culture.
And a lot of Jewish
people in the middle of the
19th century, especially in Germany,
began to feel
some sympathy for that, so that
even when they did not do it
themselves, as my parents did,
they
downplayed any
part of their heritage
except one of a strictly
limited religious cultural sort.
There are several such exchanges
where Laurel Vlock is
pushing Frei to confront
his identity.
Towards the end of the interview as
she confronts him one more time.
And actually I will end my
presentation with his words,
which I think are a good
introduction to the Q&A.
This is Laurel Vlock speaking,
"that takes us back to you and your
family and the relationship between
you and your family, which must
have been, must be or must have been
strained as a result of your
departure on your part,
even though it was clear why
it happened."
"My departure from, towards
Christianity, you mean?".
"Well, nah, not really towards
Christianty,
but away from the condition that the
family found itself in."
"Actually, no, no. That the problem
was not that, there.
The problem was, is not there.
The problem, I mean they, they
saw what I was doing as a
continuation of their own
pattern, of assimilation on the
one hand, and moving into an
academic life on the other hand.
The problem really for me is that
I am far more than a good
many other people at once
an outsider to Jewishness
and an insider.
I find that a very
difficult way of--"
unintelligible, it's, it's not clear
what he says there.
"I mean, for example, if this
country were to go officially
anti-Semitic, which I don't see
coming, but nonetheless
it's something like that.
I would clearly identify myself
with the Jewish community, but..."
"Why?" is Vlock
asking.
"Well, because I think one should
always identify with those who are
persecuted.
I think that's only right.
But I think I would do so
as one whose persuasion
is one of considerable skepticism
at the same time.
There is an author who wrote a
deeply moving book, Saul
Friedlander, When Memory Comes,
have you looked at it?
And he has become a very loyal,
devoted Israeli.
And yet I think I find in that book,
I found part of the same vein.
Um, a kind of inability
to get two halves of
his personality together again,
except in a very tenuous way.
Well, that's true for me,
too.
But you see that my dominant
personality became secular and
Christian.
Therefore, it would take a conscious
move rather than a net,
natural, emotive response for me
to identify myself with Judaism
now.
I'm too far gone." And
he smiles.
Thank you.
Comments?
Eva?
Thank you, both for very clear
[INAUDIBLE]
Sure.
Just two points.
First of all, I
wonder whether you can see
the methodology you
would use in
the testing on this, because
[INAUDIBLE] special sources where
histor- where historians
[INAUDIBLE] how you can use his
testimony, which
[INAUDIBLE] the position of the
interviewers.
But we haven't discussed
yet the structure of the interviews.
And the second question is connected
to the first.
What about
[INAUDIBLE] stories?
Because in the first story, this,
it goes on profession, in the
profession, and
in the concentration camp, if it
had ever happened,
then once, one can
keep his or her profession,
profession, so
and that may
continue or discontinue in
the case of a...
Is totally different than in the
case of the [?
laity ?] because he
understands, understand
in the framework of assimilation
[INAUDIBLE] history of the
Central European Jews.
So the question is whether you can
use the concept of continuity
and discontinuity and
in between the
history between
that.
[INAUDIBLE].
Let's go ahead and take a couple
more questions, and then, is that
OK?
Yeah, yes, sure.
Yes, picking up where Eva left
off.
Are you looking into
how things transpired after
the war, if, if children were left
in convents and the parents didn't
return to pick them up,
whether the convent kept them,
whether the convent
gave them to the Jewish
community?
How did things play out at
the end of the war?
Take one more question.
Alright this is both [?
a fundamental question ?].
I think, that
in looking at the statistics,
that the reason
that you found so many from
Czechoslovakia is because we had
a huge project in Slovakia.
I think it's not a legitimate
statistic.
It has to do with where our
projects were set up.
We never taped in Romania.
We had hundreds
of tapes done in Czech--,
in Slovakia, and I
think it's just that coincidence.
I'm curious if you saw the
testimony of Ruth [INAUDIBLE]?
No.
Is it in the Fortunoff?
We have it, we have a sister as
well.
All right. Oh.
Um.
So this is a case that shows that
the search itself is not
comprehensive because I couldn't
find it.
So applying the four types of
search, the name of
Ruth [INAUDIBLE], it didn't come up
so, okay, interesting.
Thanks
And the other thing is, is the
male-female dichotomy
you showed.
And I think that
does tell us something.
I think people were more willing
to take women, to take girls
because they weren't circumcised.
Mm-hmm.
A boy was immediately
identifiable and a girl was
not.
And I think some of that is a
function of...
And I'm, I'm a little puzzled.
Again, I want to look at the
records again.
I know we have at least
one that I can recall, a Romanian
little boy who was converted.
And actually, we edited
it. It's in our edited testimonies
and he talks about
how it bothered him even as
a little boy, and he said he
felt that God was going
to punish him
because he was converted and Dori
has a lengthy discussion with
him about that issue.
It's Paul D.
Paul D.
Yes.
That's--
It's possible that, I can't remember
the geography exactly.
It may be Ukraine now and not
Romania.
Yeah, might be.
But it was Romania when he was born
and we usually put down
as a country
the name of the country it
was when they were born.
I would be really interested to find
out about this testimony.
Yeah. Yeah, sure.
Because it would be great to, to
finally see a testimony of
somebody who converted in Romania,
that would be great. Fantastic.
Any other questions? You want to
tackle
the ones--.
Yeah, yeah, sure. Now, coming to
Eva's first,
I know that
there are a lot of debates about
the methodology of interviews
and
a lot of questions about,
and especially with the Fortunoff
Archive at the beginning,
where there was no specific training
until they kind of created
the framework, a structure.
But at the same time, I like the
idea of letting the survivor
talk.
There are few testimonies I looked
at when some of them
were in Serbia.
There was one in Serbia where the
interviewer was actually leading
the, what was leading
the interview, really.
So he was asking so many questions
that it wasn't any more a testimony.
It was something else.
But no, the, most of the
cases I looked at...
And actually, I had that
kind of, when I saw
that, I kind of had a question
in my mind and I asked myself,
was there a specific,
and maybe you could help me here,
was there a specific
realization that the
converts' should be pushed
with these questions of identity?
Probably not, because as
far as I know, the question of
identity would appear anyway in
all the testimonies, the way in
which after the war, the experience
itself affected
these people's identity and maybe
the case of conversion because
conversion was such a big
experience.
Maybe this is why the interviewer
asked a lot of questions
and pushed about.
And how do you feel?
Do you feel Jewish?
Do you feel, how do you feel?
And, um,
but I think these questions, it's
great that they are asked.
Because, um,
because the survivor is...
Is giving his or, his or her
insight into what,
the way in which that experience
affected them.
And the results,
the answers are sometimes
extraordinary. You discover
either feelings of
embarrassment, shame,
betrayal, or
you discover, like in the case of
Hans Frei and some others,
he is not the only one.
I mean, there are a lot of others
that don't show the same
trouble by the
experience.
But the fact that the interviewer
asked all those questions
made this
kind of clarification possible.
Continuity and discontinuity,
yes, and luckily, this is why I
chose right.
Because, actually
I had a kind of dilemma,
should I pick a testimony that
is representing
the majority of the
converts I found, the testimonies
of converts I found.
If, if that was the case, then I
should have picked up
a testimony where you have
this feeling of embarrassment
and shame and betrayal.
And there are a lot of these
testimonies.
But Frei is different, and I think
sometimes by looking at the
different case,
you can have a
better sense of,
um, what is going on.
So in this case, continuity
and discontinuity, yes.
Maybe in Hans Frei's
cases, this continuity from the
regular trend.
Now, coming to your questions,
I'm,
I'm basing my kind
of conclusion on that, what I
find in the testimonies so I don't
go, I could go to
secondary literature about
what happened with these
children after
the war. And I know
there are a lot of situations where
children were not returned
to the relatives.
Oh,
yeah, all the situations, but
based on what I found,
and there are a lot of testimonies
from children,
they are grown adults
now, who
were sheltered incumbents.
There is one very interesting
testimony, actually.
There are three testimonies
of, all of
them are men, boys.
They were boys at the time.
Who found shelter
in a Belgian
convent, but
they didn't know about each other.
I think they didn't know about each
other even during the war.
And then
after the war,
there was a call, I think in the US,
for a, a reunion of all
the people who found shelter in that
specific village and
convent.
And this is how they met.
And actually the testimony
is interesting because
they are interviewed separately
and they, then, all of
them are brought together
and they are
kind of discussing,
joking, and remembering
the experience
in that specific context.
What, what surprises me most
is
the fact that this is not
so...
The topic of children
converted in convents
or Catholic households,
um,
is not a myth.
It's something real and there
are many testimonies in the
Fortunoff Archive of such type
of conversions.
In some cases you see
that they...
They are still attached to that
experience.
By the same time, you as a, as an
observer, you feel
that
the experience itself was not right.
I mean, they were taken advantage
of.
They were children not knowing too
much, but they
still were persuaded
in a way or another by families
or by convents to convert.
I did not find any situation
where a child
or a survivor talks about
his experience, that he wasn't able
to return to his family or I
didn't find such a situation.
Um.
Thank you very much for your
comments, it's, it's great.
If, if we could find that Romanian,
that would be, the Romanian
testimony, that would be great.
Women, women and
that the topic of women and
men, I
think your your insight is great.
But at the same time, I should point
out that, that was a
trend
going back 100 and some
years back,
of women being more,
Jewish women converting at
a higher rate than
men.
So that's, that's the,
all the statistics about conversion
would show that women converted
more.
But there were some other aspects
that surprised me, I didn't talk
about all the statistical data here.
Usually we assume that
Jews converted in order to
marry, or for career purposes,
but I found a lot of testimonies
mentioning conversions, conversion
the other way around.
I mean,
women converting in order to
marry a Jewish man.
There were a lot of such, a lot of
such cases. I mean, in
one of the searches, I think for
baptized, or for
converted,
I think there were like forty
results.
And almost all of them were about
this type of, so
the spouse converted
to Judaism
in order to marry.
OK, one more
question?
Because you're dealing with some
children. Uh, are
you at a stage where you're able
to interview people or that's
not within your,
your scope?
Have you spoken to Saul Friedlander,
for instance?
No. I must say that
the topic itself is bit new to me.
I'm a historian and
I'm not an oral historian.
I mostly deal with documents.
And I came to study this as a
result, as I said, as a result of
the way in which my research led
me to this topic.
I didn't do interviews before
and I have to learn a lot
in terms of, and Eva
is helping me and a lot of other
people at the Vienna Wiesenthal,
in order to understand this,
um,
complex aspects of
interviews, the way in which they
are done and
yeah, but no,
I didn't do the interview myself,
interviews myself.
Do you see that on the horizon?
While you still have the opportunity
to ask these questions?
If I would continue to look at this
topic.
Yes, maybe.
But this depends, because I'm still
carrying on with my other, so,
my research on churches' attitudes
toward Jews, Jewish Christian
relations is still there.
I mean, I'm still interested in,
in, in looking at
the way in which
churches, as organizations,
as institutions behaved.
And, um.
But if I would, if I would
carry on with this
type of research, looking at the
way in which convert, conversion
affected, then definitely I would
look into that.
But I would also have to look into
the psychological aspect.
I'm not a psychologist,
but I will have to,
to, to gain
more insight into the way in
which...
Because in some cases
and it's fascinating, some people,
some converted survivors,
they are talking about as
embarrassment, shame.
These are very profound,
very kind of serious
terms, embarrassment, shame,
and even trauma.
So I found in one interview,
one lady Holocaust survivor
talking about the experience of
conversion towards the end of
a specific section.
She is mentioning the word trauma.
And it is true.
I mean, sometimes I have the feeling
that these people all,
it is a trauma for them because on
the one hand, they...
felt the betrayal,
the fact that they betrayed the
community and the family and the
Jewish religion,
but on the other hand, they
felt attached to that
experience.
There is one instance which is very
interesting,
and the name of the survivor
is Nadia R.
And she says
the experience of conversion, of
baptism, is the first memory.
So that's my first memory.
So that's the first thing I
remember.
But immediately she says, but
that was not important at all.
So you see the, you see the dilemmas
and the struggles
to, at the same time, to
accept that, that was a powerful
experience, but at the same time to
say, you know,
that was not important because I've
still defined myself as Jew, as
Jewish, so.
Children who were in convents
or monasteries
who were not converted, but still
consider that a seminal experience.
Yes, there are a few such
experiences.
Um,
I don't remember on the top of my
head now the names of those
survivors. But there are
definitely
some cases.
There are a few cases where,
interestingly enough,
there were siblings
and one of them converted,
the other one didn't.
There were situations also when
both converted, but after
the war, one of them remained
converted and committed Christian.
The other one returned to Judaism.
So there are a lot of different
situations.
Well, in Belgium in particular.
Yeah.
You know, that was a concerted
effort.
Yeah.
Top down and bottom up to save
the Jewish children.
Yeah.
Many, many were placed in convents
and monasteries.
And were not converted.
Yeah.
But it was a seminal experience.
Yeah, it was in Belgium,
it was in France as well.
Belgium and France, I think they
are, these are the biggest countries
we have this experience.
Um.
Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE] Christian names
[INAUDIBLE].
She's also.
OK,
we're running out of time, so let's
thank both of our speakers one more
time.